تدفق الماء من باطن الارض بقوه ثم اشتعلت
النيران فتحول الحلم الى كابوس هذا مقطع
فيديو غريب لمزارع تونسي حدث معه هذا
الموقف وسط ذهول الحاضرين السلطات
التونسيه قالت ان حادثه لم تحصل من قبل
معلنه غلق البئر للتاكد من عدم وجود جيوبي
غازت
بالطبع مدام مياه حلوه طالعه من
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لشجار بين ناخبين اتراك في هولندا
في مركز للاقتراع اشرطه تدخلت لفض الشجار
الذي بدا بعد مشاهده بين ممثلي الاحزاب
المتنافسه وافادت الشرطه بان شخصين اصيب
في هذا العراق
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بعد تداولي
فيديوهات وصور لهما وانتشار اخبار عن
ارتباطهما ولكن سريعا ما كشفت وشاكيرا عن
الحقيقه وهي ان المقابله كانت بالصدفه في
سباق جائزه
بينما ذكرت بعض الصحف انهما غادر سباق
مبكرا لقضاء بعض الوقت معا في جناح
الضيافه الخاص
[موسيقى]
تعرض احد مشجعي نادي ارسنال للضرب من قبل
جماهير نيوكاسل خلال مباراه المنافسه على
لقب الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز واظهر فيديو
تم التقاطه من المدرجات مشاجره قويه
وتعرضي شاب لضرب عنيف من قبل مشجعي نادي
نيوكاسل نتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات